تقليد سعودي يمتد على مدار اربعه عقود
وتوقف بسبب الكورونا اليوم في سفاره
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في القاهره
تتلقى كل من مصر وفلسطين نصيبهم من الهدي
والاضاحي ضمن 27 دوله تستفيد من المشروع
هذا العام السفير السعوديه استضاف نظيره
الفلسطيني وممثلا عن مصر في حضور مسؤول من
البنك الاسلامي للتنميه المشرف على مشروع
السعوديه للافاده من الهدي والاضاحي
لا تقتصر فقط على محيطها الداخلي في
الموقع السعودي ولكن همم تمتد لتشمل الدول
العربيه يا صديقي الشقيقه
ودول الصديقه وهذا مشروع الحياه مشروع جيد
ومشروع طيب ومبارك وخير همم
مشروع تكافل في ما بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه واشقها في الدول العربيه والدول
الاسلاميه
والسلطات المصريه لتسليم دوله فلسطين لحوم
الهدي والاضاحي برا من خلال منفذ رفح ليتم
توزيعها في قطاع غزه
مشروع المملكه العربيه السعوديه والاضاحي
كميه من اللحوم الى المستحقين في جمهوريه
مصر العربيه الشقيقه والبالغ عددها 12,000
ذبيحه كذلك تم تخفيض كميه اخرى للمستحقين
بدوله فلسطين الشقيقه والبالغه عدد 12 الف
ذبيحه وجميع موزعها ومغلفه ومعبه ومحفوظه
ومترجمه البنك الاسلامي ما شاء الله هم
عاملينها بطريقه مبسطه جدا وسهله انها
تبقى وحدات صغيره تتوزع همم للناس على طول
مباشره
او المصريين في ظل موجات الغلاء المتلاحقه
على الجميع وفي لنفسه تعتبر تكريسا لتقليد
تكافليا مستمر بين السعوديه واشقائها تامر
نصره العربيه القاهره